so there's a lot going on in in England
politically right now in Jeremy Corbyn
who you mentioned earlier is now head of
the Labour Party what's the general
sense of the political atmosphere in
England right now because in America we
get very very little even if I just
flick on BBC for a second I mean we got
very very little of what's going on with
with basically our biggest ally in the
world yeah it's interesting because we
are facing the inverse of what's
happening here with the phenomenon of
the rise of Donald Trump
we've got Jeremy Corbyn who is populist
in the way that Trump is or on the
left-wing on politics yeah and it's the
same discourse and actually that's why
you have the horse horseshoe theory of
politics you know that actually
ultimately your left and right they come
and they end up when they go to the
extremes meeting in the middle anyway
yeah Mussolini's fascism I'm not calling
called being a fascist by any means but
what Cellini's fascism was a left-wing
phenomena and then emerged into
totalitarian fascism so they end up
meeting and and the reason that so if
you look at Corbin and Trump what they
both have in common is their
anti-establishment approach is their
total disdain for politics in the ways
that things have been going on they want
to change the status quo they're playing
on popular anger which in many instances
is there for legitimate reasons but in
other instances it's playing up the
identity politics they identify the
other so in Trump's case the Mexicans
and the wall at the city idea of
building a wall that he wants um you
know identifying the other and a lying
with some unsavory people to achieve
that it's all part of a parcel of of the
politics of our times and across Europe
were witnessing this phenomenon with the
rise of far-right populist parties and
in Greece we had Golden Dawn now equal
series syriza which is a far left
populist party and in Scotland we had
the Scottish nationalists who wanted to
break away from the United Kingdom and
the other for them were the English so
because for whatever reason people are
feeling particularly vulnerable and
insecure they are rallying around
identity politics and defining
themselves against somebody else and I
think that's a particularly it's a very
unhelpful unhealthy way to engage in
politics and it leads to more division
which is what we see playing out across
a lot yeah not only do we see it playing
out across the world but now you know we
have this massive refugee crisis which
you guys in Europe are having to deal
with much more than we are in the states
now Europe already has a huge problem
with integrating their immigrants as a
general rule especially in Muslim
communities right so what do you make of
what England or what the rest of the EU
should be doing or can be doing with the
refugee situation I think the important
thing is integration I would caution
people in there will be you know in the
United Kingdom we are overdue an Isis
attack so not if but when Isis chooses
and decides it's capable striking in the
UK I would urge people not to blame the
refugees these are people who are in
some cases who have fought Isis in Syria
and Iraq and fled since then or in other
cases who are fleeing for their lives
because they disagree with everything
that Isis is doing um of course you know
among them there may be one or two
fighters and that's neither here nor
there because 1,000 born and raised
British citizens of Gaza join Isis
anyway so they're finding it easy enough
to recruit from UK born citizens it's
not having to sneak them in with
refugees so if there are attacks I would
other people not to blame these poor
desperate refugees who need our help and
our sympathy and our understanding and
what I would consider what I would say
is important to consider for governments
on the other hand is not to repeat a
fair anybody's when what you mentioned
integration wasn't seen as important and
so what we ended up developing in Europe
and in Britain I can speak suits were
these self segregated communities that
didn't mix with one another and they
grew up you know it's possible in 2015
to be born and raised in London as a
Muslim teenager and not have a single
non Muslim friend nor a single friend
from the opposite sex and I just think
that's not a healthy psychological state
to be in so I would encourage
governments to have really really robust
and strong integration policies yeah do
you think that's that's even possible
because they're already dealing with the
integration problem that exists it seems
to me that the conversation has been
dumbed down to the point where if you
say anything if you were to say well we
shouldn't bring in more refugees right
now that people would immediately call
you racist which the truth probably is
somewhere between you know there's
obviously a certain amount of people are
going to be xenophobic no matter what
and then there are also some legitimate
concerns about what the what this can do
to societies but we so rarely have this
conversation right yeah and it's you
know at the end of the day the
immigration conversation is a bit like
these limb is in conversation that it's
immediately shut down and accusations of
bigotry are the first you know recourse
if you like of those who want to shut
that conversation down it's important
that these conversations are in fact
thrown open in the recent history the
political history of the United Kingdom
we've seen the consequences of not
having these conversations because when
these debates were shot down by the the
mainstream parties what happened as a
result is the rise of two groups one a
street protest movement and the other a
political party the u-clip United
Kingdom Independence Party they wants to
break away from the European Union in
Worcester and all immigration that party
which which started taking chunks out of
the conservative support base arose at
lightning speed in the UK headed by
Nigel Farage precisely because the main
political parties didn't want to talk
about racism and so an uglier version of
that conversation happened on the
outside on the fringes of the mainstream
because we didn't want to talk about it
and the other thing that happened was
the rise of the English Defence League
the EDL so what have been Europe's
largest street protest movement began
organizing rallies and demonstrations up
and down the country because
conversation about Islamism so what I
advocate the reason why I'm so so
heavily for having these conversations
is we don't have them in the mainstream
in a responsible way the fringes will
have them in an irresponsible way and
that's the danger of the Voldemort
effect but I refer to ya and that's very
much what I'm trying to do with this
show which is why I'm gonna have people
from all over the political spectrum
here because we need we need these
conversations so just one more thing on
the refugee thing what do you make of
the Arab countries that basically aren't
taking in
they're brothers I mean I think Saudi
Arabia has let in maybe 30 families or
something all these countries were
seeing Egypt's now letting anyone in
Turkey has done a lot Turkey's not in
our country but all but all these
countries that are doing this what do
you make of that so we go to caveat
here's the Gulf Arab countries that have
letting 0 refugees whereas Jordans
Lebanon and these surrounding countries
that aren't Gulf Arabs have millions you
know Jews and so there is that
distinction to be made Jordan is
overflowing with refugee camps and tents
and the so is Lebanon but the Gulf Arabs
you know the Emirates Saudi Arabia these
countries Kuwait they they they think
that actually they think that their
responsibilities have been met simply by
providing funds to the refugee camps and
I think that's a particularly
interesting point there to look at as to
the just with like just as with a Syria
conflict there are certain
responsibilities that the regional
powers have to deal with conflict in
their own back gardens and in their own
region and unfortunately that hasn't
been happening on the one hand we
complain when the international
community led by the United States of
America intervenes and you're on the
other hand when when no intervention is
forthcoming we complain because we're
saying that no one cares about all the
women and children dying and actually
that the only way around this is to say
okay if you don't want international
intervention then take responsibility
for your own regions and and intervene
yourselves and that applies to refugees
and it applies to the war in Syria and
dealing with that through political and
diplomatic and military means and I'm
very critical unfortunately I don't
think these Gulf countries have been
doing even nearly enough yes regard and
by the way I don't want to just blame
the Gulf countries or any of the Arab
states because we just saw at the UN in
these last couple of days there seems to
be now be this new alliance between Iraq
and Iran and Russia and again as to what
you just said the more the US pulls out
it seems the worse it gets and every
time we go in we seem to make it worse
so there are no easy answers here I
think is the is the ultimate conclusion
so I have one more thing for you
because I've been trying to end all my
interviews on on some sort of feeling of
hope and actually
you've done a nice job of giving us some
hope this whole way through but I really
sense that there has been over the last
couple months
a real secular awakening I sense it in
in the response I'm getting to the
videos the Facebook messages people
trying to me emails the tweets the whole
thing that people that secular people
that want to base their values on
humanism and not on you know magical sky
gods and all of that stuff that they're
really waking up and I think you've had
a part to do with it I think Sam I think
many other people do you sense that -
please tell me you do or I'm in a lot of
trouble
I sense particularly that more what
voice is that I call the minorities
within the minority you know
people on the left that we've spoken
about earlier they tradition and care
about the minority communities but
actually I'd say to them that if they
really worth their salt if they really
want to test their mettle what they
should be carrying it up other
minorities within those minority
communities the gay Muslims the lesbian
Muslims the X Muslims the the the
liberal Muslim voices the feminist
Muslims and the minorities such as the
Christians in Egypt as Edie's in Iraq so
those minorities within minority
communities I sense have been rallying
and waking up in galvanizing I think I
sense more and more Muslim voices coming
out to speak against not just Islamism
but also
Islamic religious conservative ISM and
we get messages every single day we have
people asking to join our organization
to help us to work with us and I think
that's really it's fantastic because if
we're gonna really defeat the scourge of
theocratic fascism and if we're going to
help reform the way in which Islam is
interpreted today and those voices are
really the crucial voices that we need
to hear from yeah well you've been a
huge part of that so I thank you for
taking some time while while you're in
New York your book with Sam Islam in the
future of Tolerance he's already sold
out the pre-orders already sold out on
Amazon it's coming out way it's coming
out in a couple days in the bookstores
right yeah it will hit the bookstores
very soon and then everyone hope you'll
be able to get a copy and then actually
after that the Kindle version will come
out - there is a Kindle version coming
out but it will come out after the
bookshelves all right well I'm really
glad that we got a chance to do this
almost face to face we concede you but
one day we'll be able to have a beer and
do it for real and good luck with with
all your work appreciate it thank you
Dave